Romeo, Romeo. Wherefore art thou.
We've all read Shakespeare in school
and for many there enough vowels,
these dyes and dies to
make their heads hurt,
but just what are these archaic pronouns
does seem to have bill place in modern
society. Today we're going to
talk about val, the Di and dine,
why you is used as a subject pronoun in
the plural and the singular and how all
of this has affected how we speak.
But first a brief English history lesson.
Old English,
the predecessor to our modern variety.
It was spoken from four 58 D to
10 66 80 and resembled German.
This is because English and
German share a common ancestor.
They can bolt trace their lineage
through the Germanic Klein,
but they developed independently English
being highly influenced by French and
Latin among other languages that change.
The middle English has said specifically
at 10 66 80 because this year marks the
Norman conquest of England,
the Normans.
We're residents of northern friends who
spoke a language that was a predecessor
to modern French. We don't have a lot
of time to go into a lot of detail.
So suffice it to say that guy with a
really cool sounding name really in the
second Duke of Normandy or later William
the conqueror defeated a guy with a lot
less cool sounding name,
Harold and took control of England during
the Middle English period of 10 66 80
to 1458 d English
underwent a lot of changes,
not the least of which was the extensive
barring of both French and Latin words.
Early modern English spoken from 1458 d
tour around the turn of the 18th century
was the language of Shakespeare and the
language of the King James version of
the Bible and the English that we're
most concerned with today. First,
let's talk about pronouns.
Just stay with me. Pronouns,
take the place of a noun in a sentence.
And in today's English we have quite a
few which can be divided into several
categories.
Subject pronouns like I,
she and they are used as the subject
of the sentence. I liked cheese,
object pronouns like me, her and then
our use as the object of the sentence.
Cheese likes me there also
reflexive pronouns like myself,
herself and themselves cause
that's of determiners like my,
her and there and possessive
pronouns like mine,
hers and theirs.
So what does all this have to do
without the die and die in Shakespeare's
English and an older forms of English
as well that was used where we use the
singular you in today's English you are
cheese would have been rendered thou
art, cheese and Shakespeare's English
where thou is the subject pronouns,
cheese likes.
You would have been rendered cheese like
if the where the is the object Pronoun,
your cheese stinks would
have been rendered thy cheese
stinketh where thy is the
possessive determiner. It's not my cheese,
it's yours would have been rendered.
It's not my cheese,
it's the line where the line is the
possessive pronoun but there's more here
than meets the eye because you also
existed in Shakespeare's English as did a
more curious word.
Ye How do you and ye relate to bow and
the four that we have to go back a little
further notes to simplify
things and to avoid confusion.
I'm going to use modern spellings and
modern pronunciation so they'll be trying
to tell me that I don't know how to
speak old English and middle English,
which you know I don't in early middle
English and in modern English that was
used exclusively to refer to an
individual in this second person.
If I were to talk to my friend,
I would say thou art my friend.
The was used exclusively
as the second person,
singular object Pronoun I love Thee.
Ye on the other hand was used exclusively
to address multiple people in the
second person.
Ye are my friends.
You was used exclusively as the
second person, plural, object Pronoun.
I love you.
You meaning I love you
all or I love you guys.
You in the plural.
It was in middle English through French
influence that English speakers first
started to use ie to not only refer it
to a group of people but to also refer to
an individual in a more formal manner.
To show respect.
It was originally something that you'd
say to your king, you are very wise,
your majesty or in modern
English you are all very wise.
Your Majesty kind of like you're so great
that you must be better than just one
individual person.
You was later used to respectfully
address any superior person.
Speakers of French will know that Wgu
is a formal way to address an individual
and then it's also used to
address a group of people,
but they may not know that who used to
be used exclusively to address multiple
people.
So when Shakespeare's Day you'd use vow
with your buddies or anyone inferior to
you and he with superior individuals
or when addressing multiple people.
So why did we stop using ye as a subject
pronouns and start using you for both
the subject pronouns and the object
or ma'am, basically bad grammar.
Instead of saying you are my friends
or a year my king and using the subject
from them,
people started saying you are my friends
or you are my king using the object
Pronoun in place at the subject pronouns.
How could this happen?
It doesn't make any sense.
Well one ye and you sound quite a bit of
like especially in casual speech and to
actually,
this is quite a bit like how many use me
as a subject pronoun in modern English
in certain contexts.
Some say Jim and me went to the store
instead of Jim and I went to the store
replacing the subject pronoun with an
object Pronoun throughout early modern
English III and you are used
interchangeably as subject pronouns,
but eventually you one out becoming the
subject Pronoun and remaining the object
Pronoun for both individuals and groups
as early modern English developed into
the English of today,
you began to be used more commonly to
address just anyone and thou the dye and
dine died out in most contexts.
Understandably you becoming the second
person singular subject Pronoun gave rise
to you all y'all,
you guys and the like because we
needed a way to differentiate between
individuals and groups.
Who knows,
maybe we'll continue on its present
course ended a few hundred years.
We'll be using me as a subject program
and then just about any case until next
time me like cheese.